(cris)
- Peu d'indices laissaient
présager la catastrophe,
jusqu'à ce que des pierres
se mettent à tomber, alertant
des témoins en panique
à bord d'autres embarcations.
(cris)
C'était trop peu trop tard.
Samedi, en mi-journée,
un pan de falaise s'est détaché
d'un canyon, accrochant du même
coup des bateaux avec, à leur
bord, de nombreux touristes.
Des vidéos de la scène
ont rapidementour
des réseaux sociaux.
Les conditions météorologiques
ont ralenti l'opération
de sauvetage.
Beaucoup de pluie et des nuages
ont empêché un avion
de se rendre sur place.
Les canyons du lac Furnas,
sont situés à environ 600 km
de Rio de Janeiro et à plus
de 400 km de Sao Paulo.
Selon les pompiers, les pluies
intenses des derniers jours
dans le sud-est du pays ont pu
favoriser la catastrophe.
Une brigade de plongeurs
et un hélicoptère ont été
déployés sur les lieux.
Parmi les victimes,
des enfants secourus
par les premiers répondants.
Le président brésilien
Jair Bolsonaro a tenu
à souligner, r,
l'intervention rapide
de la marine brésilienne,
venue au secours des victimes.
Le site, prisé pour sesé pour x
vertes, ses parois rocheuses
et ses cascades, attire environ
5000 visiteurs chaque week-end.
Ici Élyse Allard,
Radio-Canada, M